two passports one man Musa cha Healy is
now officially both German and Turkish
he's celebrating with Germany's
Commissioner for integration both were
born in Germany and grew up here
both have Turkish parents citizenship
means more than having a passport for me
it's more emotional than that it's part
of my identity
people like cha Healy no longer have to
choose between their parents and their
own country of birth Deutschland Germany
is at last properly recognizing children
who were born here including those with
a double citizenship who have different
cultures and different languages and
easy home until now people born in
Germany to foreign parents and raised in
the country had to choose between
staying German and giving up their
parents citizenship for the last century
German citizenship was determined mainly
by ancestry in 1999 Germany's Social
Democrat green coalition government
tried to change that they moved to grant
automatic German citizenship to children
born in the country and let them keep
that of their parents but conservative
opposition led to dual citizenship being
restricted to those with EU passports
only Musa Shah Healy still has a letter
from the authorities from that time the
cliche italian the greek and italian
friends i grew up with way but to keep
both passports i had to give up one of
mine that was unfair
that injustice is now history for the
most part children who are born and
raised in Germany will be able to keep
their German passports along with any
others they might have